madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir ça
y est nous savons maintenant à peu près
à quelle sauce nous serons mangés l'an
prochain tout au moins sur le plan du
prix du pétrole les pays membres de
l'opep se sont mis d'accord en début
d'après midi en 1979 le pétrole
augmentera à la production de près de
15%
14,43 % très exactement voilà philippe
sassier qui demande quelques
explications et la première c'est bien
sûr de savoir comment cette augmentation
pas se traduire pour la france yayi
alors aux médicaments cette hausse du
pétrole total est plus forte que ce qui
avait été prévu il frôlera en 1979 15%
parce qu'elle sera progressive sera
étalée sur plusieurs mois notre facture
pétrolière l'an prochain ne sera aux
montants définitifs que de 10% mais à la
fin de l'an prochain nous paierons
effectivement 15% plus cher notre
pétrole
monsieur giraud vous êtes avec nous ce
soir
merci d'être venus quel va être
l'incidence cette hausse décidée par les
pays de producteurs de pétrole les pays
membres de l'opep pour les consommateurs
d'essence et de fioul que nous sommes
tous vous moi philippe sassier tous les
français d'après ce que nous savons la
hausse
formulée au 1er janvier sera seulement 2
5% la répercussion n'intervient vous le
savez que vers le 15 février et pour
l'essence elle signifiera 3 centimes par
litre l'essence elle super 3 centimes
par l'ip d'augmentation à la fin de
l'année si le programme annoncé par
lopez est effectivement réalisé cette
augmentation aura été triplé c'est à
dire un timbre à frisera les 10 centimes
par litre en ce qui concerne le fuel
l'augmentation sera de 2 centimes
par litre le fioul domestique
elle sera également tripler d'ici la fin
de l'année mais il faut pas oublier
qu'il y aura des répercussions
indirectes par exemple aussi sur le prix
de l'électricité
ces dix centimes sont à bien sûr seront
ajoutés aux 13 centimes d'y signer dans
le budget 1079 pas tout à fait le
mécanisme ne sera un peu plus compliqué
nous avons comme chef de hausse la
fiscalité qui a été introduit dans le
budget
le fait que le dollar et s'est raffermi
depuis la date où on a fixé les derniers
de prix et quelques mesures techniques
nous avons par contre une baisse due à
l'arrêt du prélèvement au bénéfice de la
fameuse cagnotte qui finance les
économies d'énergie et le résultat
global sera que l'essence est super
carburant le gouvernement va en discuter
dans l'est dans les jours prochains
augmentera vraisemblablement au 1er
janvier
tout bien pesé de l'ordre de 10 à 12
centimes par litre et la deuxième hausse
interviendra 15 février au 15 février
elle devra tenir compte là encore du
dollar et de l'augmentation des pays
producteurs elle se lèvera probablement
autour de 3 centimes par litre donc la
cagnotte va permettre quand même
d'atténuer un petit peu dans la cagnotte
permet d'atténuer largement les hausses
puisqu'elle permet de reprendre
6,85 centimes par litre très exactement
que ça va faire une augmentation totale
sur l'ensemble de l'année de combien
pour le super et bien si nous dans le
calcul de 10 à 12 au 1er janvier puis
une dizaine de centimes d'ici la fin de
l'année se fera donc d'ici la fin de
l'année 79 un peu plus peut-être de 20
centimes par litre mais alors faut-il
prévoir un effort supplémentaire en
matière d'économie d'énergie dans
l'année 79 jeu supplémentaire oui bien
sûr il possible en plus de dix ans que
la politique énergétique que mène le
gouvernement français depuis quatre ans
reste extrêmement fondé et cette hausse
n'était pas imprévisible par conséquent
la politique d'économie d'énergie qui a
été révisé par le gouvernement très
récemment tenez compte de cette
éventualité va donc se dérouler comme
prévu monsieur le ministre hausse des
prix hausse des cotisations sociales
décidé il ya quelques jours
augmentation du chômage et dans quelques
jours augmentation du prix de l'essence
et du fioul alors en tant que membre du
gouvernement est ce que vous pouvez
vraiment souhaité pour noël et bonne
année aux français qui nous écoutent ce
sport je crois que personne n'a jamais
caché aux français que nous devions
faire des efforts pour faire face à une
crise économique mondiale qui se déroule
depuis 1974 et qui ne va évidemment pas
être atténuée par la mesure qui vient
d'être prise on peut s'attendre à ce que
les mesures qui ont été décidées si
elles sont réalisées comme elles ont été
annoncées accroissent l'inflation
mondiale probablement portent atteinte
certaines devises je pense qu'il faut
que les français ont conclu qu'ils
doivent effectivement redoubler
d'efforts la vie moderne est difficile
de ce giro je remercie ces millions de
belges étaient appelés aux urnes
aujourd'hui des élections générales pour
renouveler les deux chambres le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale des élections qui
décideront aussi dans un certain sens
peut être de l'avenir de la belgique le
parlement qui sortira de ce vote sera
constitue en cela veut dire qu'il pourra
modifier la constitution belge et la
belgique sera bientôt un état fédéral le
tout est de savoir s'il s'agira d'une
fédération à deux c'est à dire flandre
et wallonie + bruxelles ou d'un état
fédéral à 3 flanc ou à l'ani et
bruxelles
les premiers résultats doivent
maintenant être à peu près connu de
bruxelles mon confrère de france inter
quentin dickinson c'est dans l'ordre
mais sans enthousiasme que les six
millions et demi d'électeurs belges se
sont rendus aux urnes ce matin pour
élire un parlement dont la tâche sera de
remanier la constitution et de doter le
pays d'une structure fédérale la
première estimation globale est tombée
il ya quelques minutes elle porte sur 10
% environ des suffrages exprimés on
assiste semble-t-il à une stagnation des
démocrates chrétiens flamands de
monsieur dean demande ce dernier avait
fait une campagne personnelle très
importante si cette fourchette devait
être vérifiée cela constituerait une
forme de désaveu en vals aunis les
régionalistes du rassemblement wallon
avaient été les grands perdants des
dernières élections aujourd'hui ils
paraissent remonter le courant au
détriment surtout des libéraux et des
socialistes
seul élément frappant à l'heure qu'il
est jusqu'à 14 % de bulletins blancs ou
nuls une forme sans doute de
protestation contre le vote obligatoire
tenez puisque nous sommes en belgique
une information que nos confrères de la
télévision belge accaparé probablement
par les élections n'ont pas eu peut-être
le temps de vous transmettre les
résultats du championnat de belgique de
football et c'est beveren avec 25 points
qui reste leader devant anderlecht et
antwerp second avec 21 points la chine
l'annoncé hier de l'établissement de
relations diplomatiques entre washington
et pékin continue de rencontrer un
immense écho dans le monde
mécontentement à taiwan que nous
connaissons mieux en france sous le nom
de formose mécontentement à moscou et
dans les pays satellites de l'union
soviétique à l'exception peut-être de la
roumanie satisfaction en revanche dans
plusieurs pays de l'asie du sud-est et
en europe occidentale satisfaction aussi
en chine où le quotidien du peuple se
félicite ce matin de l'accord réalisé
entre pékin et washington
c'est le président hu à quoi feng
lui-même qui a annoncé la nouvelle à la
télévision et dans les rues de la
capitale avec des sourires qui n'avait
pas l'air de commandes la population a
commenté la bonne nouvelle qui vient
s'ajouter à toutes les précédentes
depuis que le gouvernement a décidé de
sortir le pays de son isolement quasi
monacale en établissant des relations
diplomatiques avec les usa la chine va
enfin devenir une nation tout à fait
comme les autres commentait ce matin les
journaux américains qui insiste sur les
conséquences économiques de cet accord
un marché de près de 900 millions de
personnes le quotidien du peuple insiste
lui sur l'aspect politique de la
décision qui permettra maintenant aux
états unis à la chine de lutter ensemble
contre l'impérialisme soviétique
mise en état d' alerte de toutes les
troupes installations de barbelés autour
de l'ambassade américaine dans l'île de
taïwan les chinois de l'autre chine ont
accueilli la nouvelle avec angoisse
pourquoi tester le premier ministre a
immédiatement démissionné les
manifestations ont eu lieu dans la
capitale les nationalistes ont la
certitude qu'ils seront très
prochainement et définitivement lâchés
par les etats-unis qui les soutenaient
depuis trente années cette inquiétude
trouve un écho à la mairie comme
monsieur vente vient d'annoncer que
l'année prochaine les usa continueraient
leur fournit sur fourniture d'armes à
taiwan en quantité limitée toutefois il
a également souhaité que le problème de
la réunification des deux chine soit
résolue pacifiquement c'est aussi l'avis
d'un député chinois qui a déclaré hier
que des négociations pourrait commencer
très prochainement
michel poniatowski 20 d'effectuer un
voyage en chine populaire il était
notamment porteur d'un message personnel
de monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
monsieur waku offagne georges bartoli
qui a rencontré l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur cet après midi lui a demandé
comment la chine concevait désormais sa
coopération avec le reste du monde
l'ensemble de la technologie l'économie
chinoise est très en retard et ils ont
décidé donc de s'adresser au reste du
monde pour se moderniser heureusement
pour l'instant s'est excusé moi c'est
surtout le japon et les etats-unis non
non ces fonds 3 par d'abord le japon
parce que le japon est profondément
complémenter de la chine le japon à la
technologie et l'argent mais n'a aucune
matière première et aucune énergie ce
que la chine un très largement dont il
est certain que dans l'évolution qui est
en cours le japon de bénéficiaires un
très largement de ces échanges il ya
ensuite les états unis les états unis
qui intéressent la chine d'abord sur le
plan politique nous en parlons tout à
l'heure mais sur le plan de la
technologie avancée les chinois sont
décidés dans certains secteurs à
utiliser la technologie la plus avancée
possible et puis il ya un troisième la
troisième série de clients et c'est
l'europe
ce qui intéresse
les chinois dont les clients européens
c'est leur capacité de concurrencer deux
autres secteurs c'est aussi pour des
raisons politiques de soutenir un
secteur géographique il en paraît
important dans l'évolution du monde à
l'heure actuelle c'est pour ça que nous
allons rendre à nous aussi des armes
régime et c'est pour cela que la france
représente un client à ces privilégiés
politiquement impose de sa politique
européenne et aux de sa politique
africaine
quand vous voyez là la gamme des clients
1 le japon les états unis et l'europe
avec un client un peu privilégiés qui
est la france et c'est tout à fait
normal lorsque vous êtes dans une
situation de ce genre vous ne voulez pas
dépendre d'un seul client vous essayer
de multiplier les clientèles possible
est-ce qu'on peut rester
la chine communiste en chine de mahmur
quand on s'ouvre comme ça toutes sortes
de pénétration en économie
ils auront certainement ils en sont
conscients des problèmes psychologiques
des problèmes politiques importants je
crois que le mouvement qui est en cours
est un mouvement de modernisation
qui est un mouvement qui en entraîne à
un progrès économique qui entraînera un
niveau de vie très améliorée en chine
correspond au désir profond de la
population
la russie elle enfin le mignan
soviétique reste tout à fait au bord du
chemin ne participent pas du tout à
cette mise en valeur du conte d'hydra
sciatique non pas maintenant elle
considère d'ailleurs que les événements
qui sont en cours constituent à terme
une menace pour elle un danger militaire
bien sûr mais économique et sur ce plan
elle n'est peut-être pas la seule parce
que pour nous aussi il y a un problème
le branchement du japon sur la chine
signifie que non 15 20 ans nous en ont
pas en face de nous un concurrent le
japon mais ne rompt ce qui équivaudra à
quatre ou cinq ou six japon et donc il y
a un problème très important et il ya un
problème politique
c'est que le japon et la chine vont
constituer un centre de cristallisation
pour tout le sud est asiatique
c'est à dire un ensemble d'un milliard
et demi à 1 milliard 600 millions
d'habitants et que ceux-ci
nécessairement représentant pas tout à
fait le tiers de la population du monde
mais presque il sera un un point très
important émergence très importante dans
le monde la paix dans le monde passe en
tout cas par la paix en asie et l'accord
sino américain on est l'un des exemples
mais il en est d'autres et demain à
20h30 antenne 2 vous invite d'ailleurs à
suivre une émission spéciale consacrée
entièrement à la paix sur la terre une
émission spéciale que vous présentera
jean pierre elkabbach l'occasion de
parler des grands sujets qui préoccupent
l'opinion internationale et c'est ainsi
que monsieur machine à yann le ministre
des affaires étrangères d'israël
participa à notre émission la politique
cependant n'occupera pas seul le devant
de notre plateau raymond devos sera là
comme georges brassens catherine ribeiro
et l'orchestré symphonique de la garde
républicaine de paris une liste non
exhaustive bien sûr demain lundi à 20h30
donc sur antenne 2 la paix une émission
spéciale réalisée par la rédaction
d'antenne la politique française deux
centres d'intérêt aujourd'hui le débat
au sein de la minorité du parti
socialiste tout d'abord et la
controverse au sein du rpr ensuite le
crs donc d'abord avec cette information
que me communiquent daniel grandclément
les militants de l'ailé gauche du parti
socialiste sorte divisé de leur colloque
qui s'est déroulé hier et aujourd'hui à
epinay près de paris jean pierre
chevènement georges sarre et les autres
dirigeants du crs reste cependant
largement majoritaires plus de 90% des
délégués vont sans doute signé leur
texte les dissidents regroupés autour de
christian pierret le député des vosges
feront connaître leurs intentions au
début de la semaine prochaine certains
donc pourrait se rallier à monsieur
michel rocard cette rupture il faut le
dire ne modifie pas fondamentalement les
équilibres du parti socialiste le
serait-ce je vous le rappelle celle aile
gauche marxiste du parti socialiste elle
représente environ 25% des militants du
parti et puis noël copains au sein du
rpr c'est aussi le problème de l'unité
du mouvement qui est posée depuis
quelques jours maintenant oui évoquons
s'ils voulaient les deux derniers faits
il ya d'abord les échanges de lettres
entre jacques chirac alain peyrefitte et
puis les déclarations d'alexandre
sanguinetti au journal du dimanche
la lettre de jacques chirac d'abord
c'est à la suite d'une série de raids de
réaction en chaîne une lettre dans
laquelle président du rpr demande au
garde des sceaux de démissionner du rpr
on dit que le garde des sceaux n'a pas
encore reçu cette lettre mais ses amis
de seine et marne ont eux déjà répondu
pour lui ils sont indignés qu'on adresse
une telle demande à leur leader
conclusion donc il est exclu que alain
peyrefitte démissionne du rpr mais ce
qui frappe c'est la convergence vous
voulez entre alain peyrefitte et
alexandre sanguinetti
ce sont tous les deux d'anciens
secrétaires généraux non mais ils sont
tous les deux anciens secrétaires
généraux de l'ue dr ne sont pas là
maintenant cela est au gouvernement
alain peyrefitte et l'autre alexandre
sanguinetti annoncé il ya quelques temps
qu'il était maintenant dans l'opposition
mais tous les deux adresses les mêmes
critiques à jacques chirac qui ne sont
pas seulement des critiques sur la
direction politique qu'il suit mais sur
la façon dont il conduit le rpr et il ya
des expressions piquante celle d'alain
peyrefitte parlant des personnages
occultes qui sont autour de jacques
chirac est celle d'alexandre sanguinetti
qui lui parle de la bande des quatre
alors on peut se demander s'il ne va pas
y avoir une action politique au sein du
mouvement rpr comme on dit c'est ainsi
qu'il pourrait avoir également une
action politique au sein du groupe
parlementaire rpr mais s'il est au delà
de ces événements je crois d'une façon
plus générale on peut faire ces quelques
remarques sur les points sur lesquels
jacques chirac dans sa politique
européenne actuelle paraît le plus
vulnérable il ya d'abord je crois la
coupure qu'il établit entre ce qui se
passe au parlement et ce qui se passe
dans le pays au parlement soutien au
gouvernement et dans le pays et
lancement d'une grande offensive contre
la politique européenne du gouvernement
le deuxième point c'est le risque d'être
accusé de collusion avec le parti
communiste et le troisième point c'est
le risque d'être accusé comme l'a fait
alain peyrefitte de mettre en cours de
fonctionnement les sitution ou comme
l'ont fait d'autres membres de la
majorité de mettre en cause le président
de la république or là nous sommes
ramener un peu en arrière de 2 environ
lorsqu'à l'occasion de la campagne des
municipales
monsieur chirac elle était accusée et de
lancer un défi au président de la
république il s'en était défendu mais
c'est bien là que se situe le seuil
comme on dirait que comme on disait
autrefois c'est bien là que se situe la
rive du rubicon et nous verrons cela
cette semaine deux jours après l annonce
par un journal égyptien de la mort du
président houari boumédiène un
communiqué médical a été publiée cet
après-midi à alger selon ce communiqué
l'état de santé du président algérien
s'est brusquement aggravée hier soir en
espagne un officier supérieur en
retraite a été assassiné ce matin à san
sebastien cet attentat n'a pas encore
été revendiqué mais la police espagnole
pense qu'il a été réalisé par un
commando de le t1 un certain nombre de
bretons ne sont pas contents de la sncf
et ils le font savoir depuis plusieurs
semaines plusieurs trains ont été
arrêtés encore aujourd'hui par les
manifestantes ces derniers protestent
contre la suppression de certains arrêts
et surtout contre la modification
d'horaires modifications d'horaires
intervenue depuis le 1er octobre
le malade qui a suivi qui a subi par
dont une greffe cardiaque à l'hôpital
cardiovasculaire de lyon je vous
l'annonçait hier soir ce malade est mort
ce matin depuis son opération monsieur
dufour il est âgé de 57 ans était resté
plongé dans un coma profond je ne
reviendrai pas sur l'essentiel des
résultats sportifs de ce week end robert
chapatte et mes amis du service des
sports vous ont pratiquement tout dit en
une heure à partir de 19h le critérium
de la première neige première grande
compétition de ski de la saison se
déroulaient cependant à val d'isère ce
week-end pas de victoire pour les
français on en attendait pas d'ailleurs
dans une descente féminine ou anne marie
paule moser continue de dominer l'élite
mondiale
il a plus courir deux fois la descente
de val gardena ce matin il y à cause
d'une panne de chronométrage l'épreuve
était annulée par le passage des numéros
22 mai déjà ce matin c'est le norvégien
erika qui avait réalisé le meilleur
temps cet après midi second départ est
nouveau succès pour le norvégien il
avait neigé le soleil était revenu et
c'est sans problème que acquiert déchets
n'est parvenu à s'imposer jusqu'à
maintenant spécialiste du géant le
norvégien a depuis pris goût à la
descente l'année dernière il avait déjà
terminé 3e et 2e dans les deux descentes
de lax les suisses eux compter
aujourd'hui sur une victoire de peiffer
muller deuxièmes houillères ou encore de
valter vesti troisième hier encore
vestine pas terminée et péter müller a
dû se contenter aujourd'hui de la
seconde place quant à franz klammer il a
dû lui se contenter de la cinquième
place
après les victoires de rides en autriche
puis devant le shérif hier à val gardena
la situation descente apparaît toujours
plus incertaine clameur ne domine plus
la spécialité comme par le passé et la
coupe du monde de descente possède pour
l'instant deux leaders inattendus quel
rider petter muller ex-aequo avec 40
points
et puis il y avait un tiers c'est cet
après midi tiercé qui se courait à
vincennes dans le prix de blois 2250 m
emploi finalement c'est farandole unique
qui l'a emporté devant phalempin et
fétiche du logis mais pour fétiche du
logis il a fallu avoir recours à la
photographie les rapports pour une
combinaison 11 6 10 7 pour 5 francs 11
1257 france 50 dans l'ordre pour 5
francs dans un ordre différent
2251 francs 5 à une semaine de noël
beaucoup de français pensent qu'au
départ départ vers l'est ce qui nous
l'avons vu sur les pentes tout à l'heure
ils seront très nombreux départs aussi
vers les pays chauds mais cela est
encore réservé à une minorité une
minorité de touristes qui bardet
d'appareils photos vont pouvoir fixer
pour la postérité des animaux en liberté
alors pour tous ceux qui ne pourraient
pas aller voir ces animaux en chair et
en os en afrique philippe gassot s'est
rendu dans la réserve de bouna en côte
d'ivoire et s'est d'ailleurs rendu
compte que protéger la faune dans son
milieu naturel n'allait pas sans
beaucoup de difficultés finalement être
garde forestier en afrique c'est encore
dans une certaine mesure une grande
aventure
la réserve de bouna a été créée par les
français il ya plus de 40 ans l'époque
où l'on ne parlait pas d'écologie et de
protection de la faune c'était une
réserve de chasse qui ouvrait six mois
par an depuis 74 elle est devenue parc
national par un besoin impératif sous
peine de voir des espèces disparaître
totalement le carnage a été stoppée
chaque année ceux qui ont troqué le
fusil pour l'appareil photo mais
touristes amateurs d'animaux viennent de
plus en plus nombreux environ 15000 l'an
dernier
pour garantir la fête sauvage dans cette
réserve d'un million cent cinquante
mille hectares 150 gardes forestiers
sont répartis autour du périmètre que ma
soeur au poste de kata
tous les jours des patrouilles
sillonnent les pistes qu'il convient de
savoir où se trouvent les animaux pour
assurer leur protection et pouvoir aussi
informer les visiteurs la vitesse en
voiture et réglementaires et il est
interdit de sortir des pistes cela pour
ne pas déranger les espèces
c'est à ce prix qu'on sera encore dans
une génération ce qui est un buffle mais
le rôle du garde-chasse ne s'arrête pas
là le gamme des charges et surtout de la
surveillance on est
savez la salvia savait dire que celui le
parc
occupé de braconnage faisait a raconté
blake à nice il fait encore beau ici
est-ce que c'est dangereux le courir dès
lors
il est pourtant lui aussi
issu des rangs
ce qui demandera le plus de temps et le
plus d'efforts c'est de parvenir à faire
comprendre aux tribus qui de tout temps
se sont consacrés à la chasse il faut
s'orienter vers une autre activité
depuis plusieurs années le cas des
tribus de chasseurs a été pris en
considération
on a installé dans des villages des
moyens permettant des travaux agricoles
ou d'élevage mais il est bien difficile
de faire oublier les traditions quand la
majeure partie de la nourriture
provenaient des battues en brousse la
disparition du goût même pour la viande
sauvage demandera du temps cette
situation est de plus aggravée par une
véritable organisation qui se charge de
fournir de la viande de brousse à
certains restaurants en tout cas
cette réserve entre un aspect assez
inattendu pour les gens qui connaissent
justement les réserves dans un mois et
demi tout cette herbe à éléphant sera
coupée afin de permettre aux touristes
de voir évoluer les animaux nous
parlions du braconnage le braconnage et
protégés par ces termes c'est bien ça
les lobbys la tribu du nord qui chasse
est protégée sous les herbes derrière
les herbes et mené beaucoup de mal à les
trouver il faut préciser que les lobbys
sont armés l'époque des sags et des
flèches est entièrement terminée et j'ai
dans les mains un fusil de traite comme
on l'a vu au lycée le bébé est ce fusil
est entièrement fait à la main le bois
est taillé à la main même s'il ressemble
un fusil de la grande armée c'est un
physique est entièrement fabriqué ici le
canon est souvent fait avec des
matériaux de récupération
et je crois que ce qui est le plus prisé
en ce moment ce sont les tubes de
direction pour deux chevaux
inutile de préciser qu'il y avait
énormément d'accidents on ne compte plus
les mains arrachées et les visages
emportèrent il faut veiller éduquer les
populations si l'on veut continuer à
voir les troupeaux les braconniers tubes
se nourrir et à ce stade ce serait
presque morale ce mot maintenant
beaucoup le font pour de l'argent et
c'est beaucoup plus grave d'autant que
les peines pénales ne sont pratiquement
pas applicable si loin des vul alors le
garde est plutôt là pour dissuader pour
faire fuir
hippopotame est très recherchée par les
chasseurs sa chair est apprécié et c'est
un animal qui quand il est repéré et
facile à tirer donc à protéger avec sion
ça c'est la proche des 10 po qui
peut-être
ces deux jours
en fait une étude d'airparif
en côte d'ivoire on est bien décidé à
présenter les animaux autre part que sur
des cartes postales l'éléphant qui orne
le drapeau ivoirien ne sera pas le
dernier
belle bête de quimper à perpignan de
nîmes à maubeuge et de brest à
strasbourg chaque fin de semaine plus de
10000 accordéon sortent de leur étui
pour faire danser les amateurs de valse
musette alors parmi les grands maîtres
du piano à bretelles aimable et
certainement l'un des plus populaires
lee vient d'ailleurs d'écrire un livre
de souvenirs la boîte à punaises qu'il
feuillette avec alain gillot-pétré
aimable ce piano à bretelles cette boîte
à punaises ce 2ème poumon c'est votre
accordéon autant dire que c'est tout
pour vous et ça d'abord été l'outil
notre ascension sociale oui c'est mon
deuxième ventre
sans lui qu'est ce que vous seriez rojas
rêve c'est certainement dans le nord à
travailler en usine
tous les amis hongrois et grâce à
l'accord des enjeux je suis sorti un peu
dans tous les milieux
mon père était mineur il vole évolué que
j'apprenne un instrument de musique et
j'avais appris ce lac sow et le trompe
l'oeil mais je joue au football j'ai eu
un coup de pied dans les dents et après
je continue à jouer de l'accordéon
m
alors aimable pourquoi ce que vous
appelez là haut tu n'aimes t-il pas
l'accordéon les intellectuels là ils
n'aiment pas l'accordéon c'est à cause
de cette sonorité par exemple vous
prenez samson et dalila vous le jouez
avec cette sonorité l'aca leur plaira
pas
le bal populaire avant c'était toujours
jouer des démarches il des trucs comme
ça les maintenant dans les bals
populaires ont fait du disco ont fait de
la pop ont fait du cher pour ce
n'importe quoi vous croyez que dans les
bals du samedi soir les gens viennent
faire la fête comme dans le temps passer
qu est-ce qu à une heure du matin faut
mettre de l'ambiance et vers 1h30 2h du
matin faut jouer beaucoup de ce lot des
tangons martial savait que les jeunes
gens si vous jouez pas des slows et des
tangos comment voulez vous que
plus
aimable tout passe tout lasse est-ce que
l'accordéon durera toujours c'est un
instrument c'est un lancement sur leur
équipe qui pourra jamais partir
et oui sinon comment voulez vous qu les
jeunes gens enfin la météo pour demain
il fera froid sur la majeure partie du
pays les gelées qui atteindront au moins
5 de grand degré n'épargneront guère que
le littoral méditerranéen des chutes de
neige se produiront sur les alpes et les
pyrénées sur le reste du pays passages
nuageux et éclaircies se produiront
voilà cette édition dominicale de 20h
qui a été préparé et organisé par betty
dureau et j'ai eu le plaisir de vous
présenter en compagnie de tous les
journalistes d'antenne 2 est maintenant
terminée ce journal marque aussi la fin
de ma présence chez vous chaque week-end
j'espère maintenant vous retrouvez
chaque jour à partir du lundi 8 janvier
mai à midi sur antenne 2 bonne soirée et
bonne fête à tous et au 8 janvier